ce matin les associations interpellent
les promeneurs sur la plage du carbone
alors qu'est ce que c'est ça hybrid est
venue alors qu'est ce qui se passe quand
on pose des caisses qu'on peut faire à
votre avis est-ce qu'on peut les emmener
est pas exactement à la bce on peut les
ramener
là où on a acheté c'est que les enfants
sont très réceptifs aujourd'hui ils sont
vraiment conscients qu'il ya une
problématique sur l'environnement
aujourd'hui est qu'il faut prendre soin
de notre planète entreprises
environnement à sommaires car bd science
on explique au public
l'impact de la pollution sur la nature
et ce public là est très réceptif
ça me met pas en colère mais ça me
choque pourquoi ça te choque
ben c'est pas bien pour la nature et si
on veut vivre longtemps et à quoi est ce
que tu fais attention à toi même à ne
pas jouer tu aimais ordures qu'est ce
que tu fais alors enfin je les mets dans
des poubelles
toujours est ce que tes copains font
pareil ça dépend ça se fait
naturellement c'est une négation qui se
fait naturellement par rapport à notre
mode de vie notre façon de faire au jour
le jour la gestion des déchets le tri
sélectif effectivement la déchetterie et
c'est facile avec eux oui c'est facile
je pense qu'à partir du moment où dès le
départ des enfants soient éduqués dans
ces conditions ce sont des choses qui
reproduisent naturellement cette journée
information et nettoyage en mer comme
sur terre est à l'initiative de la ville
du carbet et la bonne surprise
la collecte de déchets est plutôt maigre
buvette et mémoire agréablement surprise
par contre on trouve beaucoup on trouve
beaucoup de mégots
alors ça malheureusement je pensais
qu'aujourd'hui on en trouverait beaucoup
moins puisque avec toutes les campagnes
d'information et ben on est vraiment
déçus comprends pas que les gens ne
puissent pas faire des efforts je
comprends pas c'est simple pourtant
l'endroit le plus mouillé est en fait le
bord de plage de l'ancien hôtel marouba
où les pollueurs ou non jeter leurs
déchets sans être vu pour le maire du
carbet lié encore du travail
notre but ici complètement de
sensibiliser la population de
sensibiliser de vivre est de
sensibiliser les marins pêcheurs de
sensibiliser à la propreté de son
environnement contribué à ce que sauver
la planète comme le françois et
fort-de-france le carbet a mis en place
des aires marines éducative six classes
de primaire suivent un programme axé sur
la protection de césaire un sentier sous
marin y est en ce moment réalisé